it's time for et social study you're a  quick look at what the Stars are posting  online you just do you Tyra Banks went  makeup free on Instagram the stunning 43  year old showed off her fresh-faced  smiling with her long time pal fellow  supermodel amber Valletta she's been  having all the fun I said I'm gonna  crash the party too Barack Obama seems  to be enjoying the good life since  ending his run as US president here he  is on a yacht in French Polynesia  snapping a solo shot of his wife  Michelle the adorable moment went viral  online social media users have  officially dubbed Obama the ultimate  Instagram husband Reese Witherspoon sent  a sweet birthday shout-out to her pal  Jennifer Garner on Instagram Monday in  honor of her 45th birthday the blonde  beauty posted this photo laughing with  Jen and wrote in the caption happy  birthday to my gorgeous friend who  always laughs at my jokes and my bad  dance moves  [Music]  you